Avengers: Infinity War is an event of cosmic
significance, both in our world, and in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe.
For us, it's one of the biggest blockbusters
of all time, an unprecedented culmination
of 10 years and 18 movies leading up to a
gigantic finale.
But for the characters of the MCU, Infinity
War looks primed to be their bleakest outing
yet, and with the release of its massive first
trailer, many fans are increasingly starting
to fear that some of these characters may
not be around for much longer.
The biggest potential candidate on the chopping
block is also the most powerful member of
the team: Paul Bettany's synthetic life form,
Vision.
Key to the theory of Vision's impending demise
is the fact that the exact thing that gave
Vision life in Avengers: Age of Ultron—his
forehead-embedded Mind Stone—is one of the
six powerful Infinity Stones Thanos has spent
the last decade plotting his way across the
universe to acquire.
"You know I don't know what this is?
I know it's not of this world.
It powered Loki's staff and it gave you your
abilities, but its true nature is a mystery."
"Before creation itself, there were six singularities.
And the remnants of these systems were forged
into concentrated ingots, Infinity Stones."
One shot in the trailer has Vision sprawled
on the ground in evident defeat, having his
forehead violently probed by one of Thanos'
allies, which suggests that Thanos is going
to get his hands on the stone—and if this
doesn't end Vision's life outright, he probably
won't last long against Thanos and his horde
without his powers.
In a storytelling sense, it would make sense
to take Vision out of commission for the big
Thanos fight.
The Vision is immensely powerful, so much
so that the movies have pointedly neglected
to use him during certain battle scenes, in
a similar fashion to the way they've sometimes
sidelined the Hulk.
Vision's new, more human form and his romance
with Scarlet Witch also raises suspicions
that the end is near for him.
It's a classic move: they remind you why you
love the character, and then they stick the
knife in.
Sometimes literally.
Honestly, it wouldn't be a surprise if many
of Marvel's heroes met their ends in shocking
ways in Infinity War.
Beyond the actors' expiring contracts, and
the fact that the team's mass extinction was
already teased in Avengers: Age of Ultron,
Marvel Studios' head Kevin Feige has been
vocal in his belief that the studio needs
to move forward with new characters and new
ideas.
He told Vanity Fair,
"If Marvel is going to survive, they have
to start making movies with characters who
are a little different.
They have to start allowing characters to
die."
It increasingly looks like that time of reckoning
is now.
Not only have the movies been building to
a fatal conclusion with the mad titan Thanos,
the comics on which the story is based saw
Thanos getting away with lots and lots of
murder of some very recognizable names—at
least, for a while.
In Marvel's The Infinity Gauntlet miniseries,
Thanos used the unprecedented power of the
collected Infinity Stones, which are called
"Infinity Gems" in the comics, to effortlessly
blink half of all living creatures in the
universe out of existence, including heroes
like the Fantastic Four and several Avengers.
And when the surviving heroes confronted him,
he pretty much wrecked all of them, too.
With that comic book history in mind, could
this be what Infinity War is building to?
It was previously said that the subtitle for
the fourth Avengers movie hasn't been released
because it is in itself a spoiler—does the
title refer to the Avengers' defeat?
Is Disney pulling an Empire Strikes Back on
us, where all the heroes get their butts kicked?
Was Mark Ruffalo telling the truth after all?
"Wait until you see this next one - EVERYBODY
DIES."
"DUDE!
DUDE!"
Well—maybe.
We'll know for sure when Avengers: Infinity
War finally hits theaters on May 4, 2018.
Can you even stand it?!
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!